NARRATOR: In 1830,
Mexico banned immigration
from the United States.
Why?
Well, one reason-- slavery.
But for the whole
picture, we have to look
to the history of Texas.
Before Texas was a US
state and its own nation,
it was part of Mexico's northern
state of Coahuila y Tejas.
But the region was sparsely
populated and vulnerable
to Native American tribes
seeking to reclaim the land.
So in the early 1820s, Mexico
opened its Northern Territory
to some American immigrants with
the idea that the Americans--
[gunshots]
[horses galloping]
--would protect the
region from falling
under Native American control.
To entice American
settlers, the government
offered cheap land grants.
In 1823, Stephen
F. Austin became
the first to receive
a grant and the right
to settle 300 families.
Others soon followed.
In exchange, the settlers
agreed to speak Spanish, convert
to Catholicism, become
Mexican citizens,
and abstain from keeping slaves.
But the Americans weren't
so good at holding
up their end of the bargain.
With little oversight from
the Mexican government,
most remained Protestant,
spoke English, and didn't
give a hoot about Mexican law.
With the cotton
industry booming,
cheap farmland in
Tejas attracted
droves of cotton farmers.
And cotton farms meant slaves.
By 1829, Mexico realized
it had a real problem.
[crowd of people talking]
The American population in Tejas
had swelled to nearly 20,000,
making it practically
impossible for the government
to enforce the law.
Mexico rightly feared it would
lose Tejas to the Americans.
So on April 6, 1830, in a bid
to maintain control and keep
slavery out of its
country, Mexico
passed a law intended to
curb the flood of immigration
from the United States to Tejas.
It didn't work.
The Americans kept coming.
And the law further strained
Mexico's delicate relationship
with the settlers.
Then, to make matters
worse, in 1835,
Mexican President Antonio
Lopez de Santa Anna
repealed the 1824
Mexican constitution.
He moved to centralize
Mexican politics,
stripping Tejas and the other
Mexican states of their right
to self-govern.
And all hell broke loose.
The settlers saw this
attack on their rights
as the final straw.
Their only option-- rebellion.
[gunshots]
But Santa Anna was prepared
to put any dissent down,
and violently.
In early 1836, he
marched his troops north.
Remember the Alamo?
On February 23, 1836,
Santa Anna launched
a 13-day siege on the
settlers' Catholic mission
turned fortress.
When he finally
penetrated the walls,
he slaughtered nearly
every person inside, ending
the battle but not the war.
The settlers called
in reinforcements
from the States, promising
land and free passage.
One month later,
General Sam Houston
launched a surprise
attack at San Jacinto,
capturing Santa Anna and
forcing him to sign away
Mexican ownership of Texas.
[cheering]
The newly independent
Texans were psyched.
As an independent
entity, they would
be free to join
the United States,
where slavery was legal.
But oh, the irony--
slavery, which had greatly
influenced their bid
for independence, now
practically extinguished any
chances they had for statehood.
Because back in the
US, Congress was
grappling with the
spread of slavery
as their nation
expanded westward.
Annexation of Texas would
bring in another slave state.
As Congress debated how
to maintain the balance,
Texas remained in
a state of limbo.
For nearly 10 years,
Texas struggled
as an independent
nation, suffering
from economic instability and
border disputes with Mexico.
Finally, in 1845, Texas
was admitted to the Union,
but it was short-lived.
15 years later, Texas
would secede from the US
as the country headed
towards a civil war--
[gunshots]
--over the issue of slavery.